good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock we are live from dining street
you are very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show here on sky news still
home to boris johnson despite him being
just 32 votes away from losing last
night's crucial confidence ballot as he
prepares to meet his cabinet this
morning 41 of his own mps voted to
topple him a worse result than theresa
may and she was gone within six months
the prime minister viewing the result as
a success and extremely positive so what
damage has it done to his leadership can
he survive
and can his divided party unite and what
might become of the rebel mps on the
show today the deputy prime minister
again dominic raab labour's deputy
leader angela raynor and the leader of
the liberal democrats that sir ed davey
plus will speak to one of the first
tourist coffee pm to go to get his take
on what the future holds for boris
johnson it's tuesday the 7th of june
facing the future boris johnson prepares
to meet his cabinet amid calls for him
to consider his position after surviving
a confidence ballot by just 32 votes
it's an extremely good
positive conclusive decisive result
a prime minister
of honour would look at the figures
accept the fact
that he has lost the
support of a significant proportion of
his party and consider his position
labour on the attack today planning to
force a vote on cleaning up politics
they have ignored the british public
and hitched themselves and their party
firmly to boris johnson and everything
that he represents
i'm in burnley to get the opinion of
voters in one of the most marginal tory
seats in the country
[Music]
fears for the summer holidays as more
flights are cancelled leaving thousands
of people stranded
[Music]
the u.s court issues warrants to seize
two luxury planes owned by roman
abramovich
lilybet at one prince harry and megan
share pictures of their daughter after
celebrating her first birthday during
the platinum jubilee
[Music]
good morning everyone the prime minister
is calling it a conclusive decisive
result but as johnson is preparing to
meet his cabinet this morning with a new
promise to continue delivering what
matters to the british people as he
looks to the future saying we are going
to get on with the job 41 percent of his
own mps voted against him in a
confidence ballot last night the
chancellor rishi sunak says it's now
time to move forward the health
secretary sanji javid says the result is
a fresh mandate from the conservative
party
but questions over how long the prime
minister can continue in office after
suffering a rebellion bigger than
theresa may who won her vote of
confidence but was gone within six
months questions too over whether he
will struggle to get legislation through
having lost the support of a potential
three-quarters of his back benches can
you believe that here's the moment the
result was revealed
the parliamentary party does have
confidence
211 mps backed boris johnson
expressed no confidence in him whereas
johnson held it as a win while some of
those conservatives who want him gone
still think he should consider his
position
it's an extremely good
positive conclusive
decisive result which enables us to move
on uh to
unite and to focus on delivery and that
is exactly what we're going to do and to
confirm you're ruling out a snap
election so you keep asking about it
look just yes or no i i certainly i have
no
i see no point in focusing on anything
else and i'm certainly not interested in
uh in snap elections what i'm interested
in is delivering right now for the
people of this country
unfortunately the issue can't be settled
like that
um a third over a third
of the parliamentary party has expressed
no confidence in the prime minister a
prime minister
of honour would look at the figures
accept the fact
that he has lost the
support of a significant proportion of
his party and consider his position
for the former conservative leader
william hague sharing a similar
sentiment
while johnson has survived the night the
damage done to his premiership is severe
lord haig wrote that in the times this
morning words have been said that cannot
be retracted reports published that
cannot be erased and votes have been
cast that show a greater level of
rejection than any tory leader has ever
endured and survived
deep inside he should recognize that and
turn his mind to getting it out of the
out in ways that spares the party and
the country such agonies and
uncertainties
meanwhile labour leader zakir stammer
has hit out as the tory mps who voted to
save the pm saying they've ignored the
british public
conservative mps
made their choice they have ignored the
british public
and hitched themselves and their party
firmly to boris johnson and everything
that he represents
well joining me now is conservative mp
for bournemouth east tobias elwood um
hello to mr elwood thanks for joining us
on the programme this morning what is
your view this morning on what happened
last night
yes you just quoted william hague i
think if there was normal times we would
see a resignation we'd see cabinet
members encouraging that and the party
to move on but that's not the world that
we face
this is far from a conclusive result
it's not a defeat but it's not a a win
so for the moment i accept the
democratic outcome and i encourage all
colleagues to do the same
but as you've been saying 41 percent is
a significant chunk of mps that now need
to be
included in shaping the party's future
the conduct i would say
over the last couple of days shows that
there's a lot of work to be done to
unite the party you know number 10 jacob
rispol trying to spin this all as a
remain
plot based bizarrely on an article that
i actually wrote of trying to improve
the brexit model by daring to suggest
that we join the single market you know
backbenchers need to be able to express
views and deep dives down on those those
issues but this was a almost like a
trumpian attempt to mislead and and
deliberately to distract us it shows a
worrying grasp of the concerns of about
150 colleagues about the direction the
vision of the party so there's a lot of
work to be done to uh
a reshuffle that is now required bring
in fresh talent and actually start to
focus on the bigger issues make the
cabinet construct actually work let's do
things that uh appeal to the country not
just to our base more exciting policies
and then uh you know the privatization
of channel 4 and bringing back imperial
measurements but a real economic
strategy that's actually going to help
tackle the cost of living crisis
does that mean that you're not falling
in step behind the prime minister again
uh as i say for the moment uh that is
what we're obliged to do because of this
vote and the fact that the prime
minister is determined to stay but as
you've been again uh alluding to history
will repeat itself following votes of no
confidence unless there's a massive
overhaul in the style and substance of
what we actually do we need to think
bigger much much bigger in the cost of
living crisis if you are generally
interested in bringing down the
the cost of food then let's lean into
ukraine and keep the port of odessa open
there's a gap in the market for
international leadership there we have a
a design for a modular reactor stuck in
number 10 that would help actually make
us uh more security energy security uh
uh improve our
in independence if you'd like on energy
security but it's still stuck there and
it needs to be
approved there are so many ways that we
can think bigger picture and at the
moment we're stuck in micro policies
that focus on just appealing to our base
so are you james suggesting forgive me
uh mr elwood that this is just a stay of
execution for the prime minister
yes that's exactly where we are we know
that unless we see improvements uh which
are reflected in the polls in the next
three to four months then the party does
what it does it finds way finds ways to
then uh to move on ruthless though that
may be so like i said the ball is now in
number 10's court to improve it
no it has now my support and as i say
other colleagues should support the
prime minister
as well
he said he can turn things around and
and if he can then so be it if not then
we know where this goes it leads us to
defeat at the next general election
how long does he have
well that's a good question i think
we're talking a matter of months up to
party conference um i had to show that
but it also can be done as i say in who
he brings on board you know who actually
is around the table at cabinet able to
challenge the cab what cabinet is saying
just lost your pictures for a second mr
ellwood but i'm sure that we can still
um hear you we are hearing um uh in the
papers this morning reading in the
papers this morning that seriously
disloyal mps could be suspended in other
words have the whip removed from them
are you anxious that that might happen
to you
well that isn't the way to go forward
that's ignoring the scale of the concern
here two out of every five
mps are concerned about the direction
travel of this party and uh that needs
to be brought on board uh
it shows again i think a lack of
intelligence and understanding if you
like of the genuine concerns that we're
expressing here
for the betterment of the party
um we are being told that brexit
legislation tomorrow bringing forward
tax cuts as well perhaps even a snap
election so it does look as though the
number 10 machine has been jolted into
action
well i do hope that this entire
experience has you know jolted number 10
into action and to be more inclusive uh
there was no caucus no sub tribe there
was no wing of the party that was behind
this concerns about where the party was
going uh what
you know what number 10 was actually
doing came from all callers of the party
and the
number 10 prime ministers should be
aware of that
would you support a call
for the rules to be changed so that
the backbenchers could have another vote
of confidence in the prime minister
before the year is out some suggestions
that serene brady could look at it being
within six months if that's what the
majority of the conservative party
wanted to see happen
i understand that's what the 1922
committee are actually looking at
deliberately for this reason because if
we are now going to have this day of
execution if we are now going to to
recognize the democratic outcome and
support the prime minister then then
let's give the prime minister time to
improve but as you're implying uh
methods can be made the system can be uh
adjusted uh to mean that the current
rule of allowing the prime minister an
entire year
would be changed
so is that something that you would
support
i i i would i
would see us having to go down that
direction and i would support it if
there's a requirement for it to be
introduced but as i say for the moment
uh the demo i support the democratic
outcome of what happened last night and
it's up to number 10. it's up to the
prime minister uh to act on his word to
say he can actually turn this around
turn out prospects in the polls around
as well and so that we have a chance of
winning the general election
okay good to talk to you mr elwood thank
you so much for taking the time thank
you thank you
speaking to the deputy prime minister in
a few minutes before that let's squeeze
in tomorrow here at downey street this
morning hi what do you make of that well
what a night k and the rebels like
tobias ellwood who at times seem to be
kind of a lone voice calling for the
prime minister to go turned out to be
quite numerous 148 of them 40 of
conservative mps and once they've said
that once they voted that way once we
heard some of that scathing criticism
you can't take it back and clearly boris
johnson is wounded in tobiasel was
viewed so wounded it would be difficult
for him to carry on for more than a few
months how much of a jolt has this given
downing street well look they're talking
today about unity about bringing in
policies to help people with the cost of
living such as how housing and reducing
the cost of childcare am i getting a
sense that they are desperate to reach
out to the rebels and bring them into
the tent not as yet delivery of policies
seems to be the line they are going down
but they may find it more difficult than
they think to try and do that once
you've got this many mps in outright
mutiny
um interesting that some suggestions
that if people don't fall into step
behind the prime minister they could
have the whip suspended can they do that
so i was talking to someone in number 10
about this this morning about
retribution against some of those not
all 148 of them obviously but some of
those particularly vocal and the message
i got was that when you do that you dig
two graves one for yourself as well so
that that's not what they want to do
even mps like jesse norman who called
the prime minister's handling of
partygate grotesque and that was the
strongest intervention yesterday i'm
told that there won't be fake there's no
plans to introduce any sanctions or
withdraw the whip from them in any way
but clearly there is as one member of
the cabinet put it george eustis a job
of mending fences to be done here and at
the moment it's not clear that outreach
to the party listening to them
understanding
why they were so disenchanted with the
prime minister
is necessarily the top priority the top
priority number 10 say is bringing in
new policies to help people cope with
the next difficult few months but of
course they may face
opposition from conservative mps in
bringing some of those policies forward
and at the end of the day yesterday was
a vote against the prime minister's
character and integrity and it's very
difficult to see how that can be changed
don't have a look through the papers
absolutely it's always tricky isn't it
on the road but we'll give it a go who
should i show them too hadley there we
go
uh there you go well the mirror as
expected has got boris johnson uh
looking very sad with the parties over i
think the telegraph was quite an
interesting one at the back here
this is obviously boris johnson's old
paper um conservative supporting hollow
victory tears tories apart i mean you
know downing street were briefing
everybody yesterday this is not really
that bad um but uh you know the
telegraph pretty clear that it is and
they say johnson's authority is crushed
as he wins the confidence vote and vows
to battle on but the rebels are circling
to finish him off well that's pretty the
male seasons very differently though i
think yes the male are very supportive
of boris johnson at the moment uh boris
vows al bashon they point out the
cabinets rallying around and yes number
10 i say you know saying look at how
supportive the cabinet is being compared
to say with john major when they were
all um out trying to shaft him but um
cabinet meeting today isn't that there's
a cabinet meeting today and unity i'm
sure will be the the watch word
um yes lily very sweet a knight of the
blonde knives stabbed in the back by 148
tories if 32 had voted the other way
he'd be out yes and so close if they'd
waited another couple of weeks until the
by-elections maybe they would have
changed sides but who knows
wounded johnson in peril
that's the eye for you
express express divide and i'm about
i'll lead the party to victory uh
the express and um humiliation says uh
the guardian and uh critics casting
doubt on his claim that it's an
extremely good and conclusive result and
finally sorry the time one of the times
a wounded victor and they you know they
say he's their um comment p says he's
firmly in limp on territory and that's
the risk of course that in a few months
time he cannot uh seem to carry it to to
do anything which is what theresa may
found it was like walking wading through
treacle trying to get anything done
okay uh we're going to be hearing from
dominic robin just a moment or two um he
was out yesterday supporting the prime
minister he's written a piece in the sun
newspaper this morning supporting the
prime minister and i'm guessing he's
going to be doing the same very much so
dominick robert's been one of the most
loyal lieutenants of the prime minister
throughout this whole partygate saga and
um he well along with the whole of the
cabinet have been very supportive thus
far yesterday but you compared to uh
rishi sunak who was very factual in his
tweet yesterday saying um the prime
minister has won the vote and we move on
but uh dominic raab says that this is a
win
you know one one vote over a majority is
a win and i think we can expect more of
that today but of course
i'm sure he knows and the rest of the
cabinet know that this is the next few
days are going to be very tricky if the
prime minister wants to restore
authority okay for now um tomorrow we're
going to be as i said speaking to
dominick robin just a second he will be
coming into number 10
for cabinet i'm guessing the first thing
the prime minister will do will thank
his loyal lieutenants for their support
all of them yesterday yeah loyalty is
hugely important to boris johnson
there's no surprise that we often see
stories in the papers about how those
who have been loyal um will be rewarded
i think the difficulty he has to face
now is that you know doing the uh
arm-twisting operation yesterday when um
rebels and those who were wobbling were
called up by number ten um maybe jobs
were promised during that and if you
offer people jobs you have to move other
people and that is always the difficulty
it certainly is uh tomorrow for now
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot
well as promised the deputy prime
minister is uh with us now again it's
always great to see you uh dominick rob
thanks for joining us 41 of conservative
mps voted against boris johnson and
that's just 906 days according to our
stats people after he secured the
biggest majority in a generation why did
they vote that way do you think
well look there's uh we had the vote
yesterday it's not something the
government wanted but it's something
that those who were expressing those
dissenting opinions felt was necessary
as you say the prime minister won it
with 59 that's actually more than he got
in terms of support when he was elected
leader of the conservative party um but
we've had that vote now i think it's you
know it was the prerogative of those
calling for it to have it the prime
minister won it clearly um he won it by
uh 63 votes as i said 59
and now the most important thing i think
is respect that result and to move
forward and we last night we had the
national security bill have its second
reading that's enormously important
right now with the threats from hostile
states including russia i think we
should be focused on that we've got the
leveling up and regeneration bill coming
for second reading in the house of
commons great opportunity to empower
those local leaders to drive up growth
and development in all of the uh the
so-called left behind parts of the
country we've got a national insurance
tax cut coming in july the cash grant a
400 pounds energy
rebate coming in october i've got the
the bill of rights we're finalizing the
text on there is a huge agenda and i
think it's important that we come
together and focus on the people's
priorities and get away from frankly the
westminster inside internal conversation
that has dominated
okay if 32 conservative politicians had
voted the other way
it he would no longer be in office today
how much worse was the result than you
thought it would be but they didn't and
i you know i i i come on to show i
always want to k you ask very fair
questions and i always want to answer
them as best as i can but to be honest
with you the whole point is uh my whole
point would be
all of that speculation all of that
hypothetical uh debate that's over now
we've had that vote the prime minister
won with 59
and we move forward um i don't think the
precedents apply because we've got a far
bigger majority we don't have the hung
parliament that people talk about in the
context of uh the the contest and the
the issues in
2018 uh with theresa may um and we've
got uh 75 working majority i think the
the number still is and we've got this
packed agenda and of course for the glue
and the conservative party i think uh as
well as the public interest the interest
of the country is move forward deliver
on the agenda from national security
through to leveling up to deliver on
that relief for the cost of living we've
got a bill of rights i'm looking forward
to bringing forward a victims bill
parole reform uh all of that important
work that brings people together but
above all focuses on what our
constituents and the public expect and
that's where our energy should lie now
why then take time out of your busy day
to appear on tv twice in 24 hours and
write an opinion piece in the sun
newspaper if he's as safe as houses to
make the case i always accept the
invitation to come and speak to uk
wild horses wouldn't keep me from uh
doing the early morning round uh as you
well know but look but we do need to
make the case we've got two years to
deliver and demonstrate we're delivering
and i think we're the ones with the plan
i think this prime minister uh is full
of vision determination and uh if
anything renewed energy to to get off
the westminster insider track on to the
outward-facing uh
agenda of delivering for the people um
and i believe that we've got the plan
the energy and the team uh which labor
can't match they can't rival i don't
think they're doing anything other than
carping from the sidelines and that is
where all the energies of all our mps
and the whole government should be
but if you if you can't convince or he
can't convince three out of four of your
backbenchers what hope have you got of
convincing the country
well the conservative party party's
always been a broad church there's
always dissenting voices i've ever since
i've been in as i always say mr rob
people died in broad church
well
that may be true but actually one of the
the gifts of the conservative party um
is that it does uh house if you like a
broad tent a diverse opinion but
that must come with the galvanizing
force and energy of coming together uh
to deliver for the people and not make
the life easy not give a gift to the
labour party when we do that we're at
our best and i think uh you know it was
only a year ago we won hartley pool
which uh we hadn't won
is it for 60 years um as you said
politics changes very quickly but we
need to be on the front foot delivering
for the people and i think that's the
best galvanizing force for the country
but also for my colleagues
yeah this is what one of your elder
statesmen said former conservative
leader lord hague
while johnson has survived the night the
damage done to his premiership is severe
in his words and he should know votes
have been cast that show a greater level
of rejection than any tory leader has
ever endured and survived
the writings on the wall
look william is free to he's been a
leader the conservative party he's a
commentator now he's free to commentate
i'm frankly focused on action and what
we do next and what we do is we press
through the national security bill as i
said critical for dealing with those
hostile states in particular think about
russia the leveling up and regeneration
bill i think critically important again
shows that detailed work on the plan
that only we the conservatives have got
to lift the life prospects right around
the country i'm looking forward to
debating the bill of rights and passing
that unprecedented piece of legislation
through parliament i'm looking forward
to working with pretty patel the
attorney general suella
fernandez as well on
the um whole law enforcement agenda
we're going to be talking more about
that in particular putting victims at
the center reforming parole so we can
galvanize around those things or we can
continue to commentate and debate with
um with the commentators i think that
the former is by far
the right thing to do for the country
and the recipe for success for the
conservatives
but how are you going to stop any civil
unrest within the party blue on blue as
it's called even at the top echelons i
mean the culture secretary nadine doris
yesterday uh talking about the former
health secretary jeremy hunt who she
used to work under she actually tweeted
your pandemic preparation during six
years as health secretary was found
wanting and inadequate your duplicity
right now is destabilizing the party and
country to serve your own personal
ambition more so
i mean
how are you going to stop stuff like
this happening if you're trying to be a
part of united
i think you make a good point look what
i'd say is the more we talk about the
westminster process or the internal
process the conservative party the more
of that there will be i like and respect
both nadine and um and jeremy hunt he's
one of my sorry neighbors and we will
need all of the energies of all of our
mps uh if we're going to deliver for the
people on the priorities that i've
described and frankly if we were going
to take the game to labor which uh is in
a total mess and we're letting off the
hook if we're talking to each other um
so i think it's time to come together
and i think you make the point very well
well the door is certainly open for
months of infighting perhaps made even
worse if you lose the two by-elections
which are coming up in just a couple of
weeks time you'll say in response to
that because i've spoken to you a lot
let's wait in the sea looking at the
polls
it's disastrous for you especially in
wakefield
well actually i was noticed one of the
polls that came out over the last 24
hours had uh national polls rather than
by election polls had uh us closing the
gap with labour so what i would say is
if we want to continue to do that in
relation to by-elections but also
what will matter ultimately is the
general election get on the front foot
focus on the people's priorities come
together and deliver delivered deliver
on our agenda from the economy and the
cost of living to the the crime fighting
agenda to the leveling up agenda and
that's the it's very simple and
straightforward that is the recipe for
success i believe it's a positive agenda
that brings the country together but
also my colleagues in the conservative
party together and we should be
relentlessly focused on that
that was a body swerve worthy of the
wicked rugby league front row let me
tell you what about these by-elections
look by-elections are always challenging
but look we
as i said uh politics moves very quickly
um i think we've got great candidates uh
in both tiverton
and
wakefield
we
we won hartley pool a little more than a
year ago but by-elections aren't the
acid test the acid test is the general
election we've got probably two years
and our focus should be relentlessly on
delivering sustainably long term because
that's the stuff people remember people
don't remember if we're honest and i
think a lot of the pollsters would say
is they don't remember by-elections
come the general election it's an
opportunity to express different views
about different things it's not the
opportunity to change the government and
when you have the opportunity to change
the government of the general election
people will care about the bread and
butter issues which is why we need to be
focused all our energies all of our the
talent we've got right across the piece
in the conservative party in government
on delivering for for the people of this
country that's what matters there's
nothing else really that matters
everything else is a distraction from
that laser-like focus okay it's a litmus
test on the popularity of the prime
minister is exactly what it is are you
saying even if
are you saying that even if you lose
these two by-elections the prime
minister is still solid as a rock in the
building behind me look i will be
fighting tenaciously to win uh both of
those we've got great candidates i've
been down
to tibetan i will go up to wakefield i
think they're both uh important but but
they aren't acid tests by-elections
never are we often win back at general
elections
seats that go uh one or other way in a
by-election and that's true of all
governments
what matters now is not the
froth of
westminster or indeed by elections what
matters now is are we on the front that
delivering for the people of this
country and as i said i think we should
all be focused on that national
insurance tax cut in july the energy
rebate of for the cash ground to 400
pounds in july uh in sorry in october
forgive me the national security bill
the regeneration leveling up bill the
bill of rights the crime fighting agenda
that's the forward momentum that we need
and i think
bluntly it's the right thing for the
country it's the right thing for
conservative mps to rally behind yeah
you've also got to look forward to the
covet inquiry and the privileges
committee inquiry into what happened in
the building behind me
look
these are all
challenging times we've been through
brexit uh the pandemic as you rightly
say the likes of which we've never seen
before uh we've got a war in europe but
i believe in all of these areas the
prime minister and the government got
the big calls right and ultimately
that's the question and the judgment
that's the that's the question well can
you say that in a withering tone prime
minister deputy prime minister look at
what happened with the care homes
literally elderly people were being sent
out of hospital without being overtested
to go into care homes then we had the
parties here then we had 12 billion
pounds for our test and trace where on
earth did all of that money go then we
had four billion pounds being written
off for fraud as far as the furlough was
concerned then we had the national
insurance increase and then we've had
the highest taxes in 70 years
so okay let me uh retort allow me to
list the positives and miss the
challenges uh the fastest vaccine roll
out and booster campaign in europe as a
result all of which the pm uh stewarded
through from the r d trials to
production uh as a result of which we
got the economy opened up quicker uh
with the fastest growing economy in the
g7 last year second fastest predicted
this year we're the ones with the plan
on the cost of living and the prime
minister
has shown the kind of leadership in
ukraine that meant when he addressed the
ukrainian parliament you had union jacks
flying we've had people singing god save
the queen across towns and cities uh all
over ukraine i believe that is the the
strong leadership but i don't doubt
these have been challenging times kate
but the big calls this prime minister
got right
okay we're out of time but one doesn't
cancel out the other does it
no no you're quite right and that is why
in two years time the public will assess
uh this government on the big issues of
the day and i think we've got the
answers and labor doesn't
okay my prediction for later on is that
you're going to come to number 10 behind
me for the cabinet meeting i'm going to
shout a question to you and you're going
to ignore me that's what's going to
happen
you're almost certainly right as ever
okay
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us
bye thank you joined now by uh former
boris johnson uh advisor
here we go will walton hi will
i hear will
hello okay can you hear me i can hear
you now sorry about that will uh what
are you making of uh the cabinet coming
out to rally round the prime minister
well no great surprise i mean uh dominic
rob should be hostile fast bowling from
you but dominick rob should be opening
the batting for for england such was the
the the the drop dead bat that he
managed to portray but the the truth is
kay and they they all know it and boris
knows it
this is the worst possible result short
of of losing the prime minister needed a
decisive win last night and and he
didn't get it he's told us it's
convincing it's decisive it isn't that
unfortunately it's 70 75 percent of his
backbenchers voting against him and he
wants to move on i think the problem is
that i think it's very unlikely he's
going to be allowed to to move on
and and the the bare fact this morning
is that ultimately the prime minister is
really no longer in control of this
process
you know there is a small window for him
presumably that if these two
by-elections uh don't go the way that
the polls predict and they hold on to
one or even hold on to two i think it
will be a miracle based on the polls but
if they do i think that may give
malcontents uh pause at that point um
but the other thing we can be sure of as
demonstrated by boris's statement last
night is that from in his own mind he's
going absolutely nowhere he's determined
to hang on and it'll take an effort from
senior tories to get him kicking and
screaming through the door but at the
moment i don't think he's going anywhere
okay so
can i take from that that it's all over
for boris johnson
well as i say that you know there there
are there's there's two things in his
favor you know one is that there hasn't
uh there hasn't been an election in
terms of those by-elections and although
last night was
was not decisive for the prime minister
and and there's a real problem i think
if this result had come in the wake of
two by-election losses we'd be having a
conversation about you know when the
prime minister is leading in the next
few weeks that i don't think that is a a
given yet and one of the one of the big
factors in that is that unlike say
thatcher and hazeltine back in 1990
there is no michael hesseltine there is
no big beast and i think in many ways
that's why the prime minister survived
last night it was very very close in the
end but i think that there will have
been those who were thinking about
voting against him who looked at it and
thought can we really jump you know the
best political asset we've had in 30
years the best campaigning asset we've
had in in 30 years
for the unknown and i think that that's
the big problem for those who want the
prime minister out is it's not clear who
that person is
and it's not clear also whether the
cabinet will be prepared to look at the
writing on the wall post the
by-elections assuming that they lose
them both and you know take the revolver
and the bottle of whiskey and take boris
into a room and say sorry mate time's up
if you were still in dining street what
would you be saying to the prime
minister this morning
um
you know boris will be full of
contradictions he'll be he'll be angry
frustrated confused but i think deep
down he'll he'll be very worried uh and
i'm not sure there's much i could say at
this point i think six months ago would
have said you know tell the truth get on
the front foot um you know don't
obfuscate about this but but boris isn't
one for apology and he's also not one
for change and ultimately this is a
self-inflicted wound i think there's
very little you can say it's it's
unsurprising that they're saying that
things that they're saying because they
they they can't really say anything else
but but i i would i would caution one
word of warning if i was there and he
was listening i would say this and
dominic rob is absolutely right about
this he's talking about the broad church
of the tory party and the need for unity
this morning in the papers and with the
political correspondence there's an
enormous amount of briefing from those
close to boris johnson about the
malcontents and that you know how they
should be punished and it's absolutely
outrageous and how dare they if he's
gonna have any chance of surviving and
doing the right thing for the country
and getting everything back on track
they've got to stop this nonsense you
know dominic is right they need to come
together but it's not just the
malcontents need to come together it's
the people around the prime minister
they need to grow up and and and and
stop acting frankly like this is some
sort of you know schoolyard frat or
fight and they've got to be serious
about this stuff and briefing the papers
to the extent that people need to be
punished and how dare they and all that
sort of thing i think he's rubbish and i
think the prime minister needs to get a
grip and he needs to get a grip quickly
uh just before i let you go because i
know you have to dash thanks for taking
the time to join us this morning was
there a point that was the tipping point
do you think that resulted in the prime
minister finding himself in the position
he was in last night when you saw for
example him going up the steps with
carrie johnson at uh saint paul's
cathedral and he was being booed did you
think
this is true
obviously that did not help um you know
it was very unfortunate because you
wouldn't expect that sort of crowd to
necessarily be anti-a tory prime
minister but i think you know as graham
brady said yesterday it seems that the
letters were in before that i i think
there are a lot of tipping points and
you can go back to owen patterson and
and peppa pig gate and all that sort of
thing before any of this started
and the way that they have handled this
throughout from december there are no
parties i wasn't at a party oh there
were some parties nobody cares but i
think the big problem is the lack of
contrition i think when you know boris
responded to sue gray there was a sense
that he didn't really believe he'd done
anything wrong and i think what's
happened is the tory mps have gone away
during the break and they've heard
voters and in particular now an
increasing number of tory members and
activists saying that's simply not
credible so i think if you have to look
at any point it's probably that point
but one thing i'd say to you final thing
okay um yesterday the prime minister
addressed tory mps in the 1922 and he
didn't change at all and boris is not
going to change that's he only knows
forward gear and he basically said
yesterday i'd do it all again i didn't
do anything wrong and i think ultimately
that's what is costing him at the moment
okay well great to talk to you thanks
very much indeed thank you pleasure take
care
you too uh we're live in downey street
again for you this morning uh the
morning after the night before and that
bruising vote for the prime minister
earlier i spoke to the conservative mp
for bournemouth east that's tobias
elwood he told me that boris johnson
could be out within a matter of months
if he can't turn things around
unless we see improvements uh which are
reflected in the polls in the next three
to four months then the party does what
it does it finds way finds ways to then
uh to move on ruthless though that may
be so like i said the ball is now in
number 10's court to improve it
no it has now my support and as i say
other colleagues should support the
prime minister uh as well uh he said he
can turn things around and and if he can
then so be it if not then we know where
this goes it leads us to defeat at the
next general election
how long does he have
well that's a good question i think
we're talking a matter of months up to
party conference um i had to show that
but it also can be done as i say in who
he brings on board you know who actually
is around the table at cabinet
but despite winning the vote and being
technically safe for a year under the
current rules can he survive that long
well around 41 of troy mps decided it
was time for a change in the leadership
and voted against boris johnson last
night
before that the last pm to face a
no-confidence vote was theresa may and
that was back in 2018 december of that
year nearly 37 of mps voted against her
but despite holding on she resigned from
the role within six months back in 1995
john major triggered a leadership
contest against himself only 27 of his
mps voted for his challenger john
redwood mr major continued as prime
minister but lost heavily at the general
election to tony blair 1997 it was an
absolute landslide and of course
margaret thatcher found herself in a
leadership contest when she was
challenged by michael hesseltown in
1990. like last night nearly 41 of tory
mps voted against their leader not
enough for hesseltine to win bart party
rules stated that the winner needed more
than 50 of the overall vote and to be 15
clear of the runner-up mrs thatcher
initially said she would contest a
second ballot but then withdrew just two
days later
well joining us now is deputy leader of
the labour party angela rainer hello to
you ms rainey thanks for joining us i
suppose oh yes you're stuck between a
rock and a hard place this morning
aren't you because you're glad to see
what happened to boris johnson but you
i'm guessing you want him to stay in
post now until an election
no i don't want boris johnson to stay in
post because as you know many of the
public see politicians in general as uh
untrustworthy and i think boris johnson
is pulling down the standards in public
life which is why we've got the motion
today to uphold them but i think he he's
doing a very disservice to the country
and it's pretty clear now that the
british public have lost all confidence
in boyce johnson i mean if you can't
have a prime minister that follows his
own rules and doesn't lie to parliament
and lie to the british public then where
is the standards you know we've lowered
the tone so bad that um you know we
could get away with just about anything
so i don't think it's a good day i think
he is mortally wounded now and i think
that you know he's he's only got an
eighty uh eighty on majority within
parliament and therefore he's pretty
clear that over 70 of his backbenchers
didn't back him so i think he should
have done the right thing by now i'm
resigned already but this prime minister
doesn't really consider himself to
follow rules
but don't you want a wounded prime
minister in position while you sort your
party out
and no i think you know our party
obviously in 2019 in the general
election lost badly and i think since
myself and care have taken over we've
been making steady progress if you'd
have said we are where we are today uh
back then i think most people would have
laughed at us but we know we've got work
to do but i think you know when you've
got a prime minister who lies to the
british public who breaks his rules i
mean number 10 was the most heavily
fined building a house in the whole of
the united kingdom when it came to the
colvid rules cleaners were having to
clean up vomit and wind off the walls i
mean it wasn't
a one-off this was serial partying going
on in number 10 when people couldn't see
their loved ones i don't think it's
going away i think every day that boris
johnson is prime minister is damaging
the standards in public life and it
damages us also i don't think it's a
good thing that he continues i think
he's arrogant i think he's dismissive i
think he's a liar and i don't think he
should hold the office of prime minister
yeah but you you as a party are still
not ready to run the country are you
i think we are i think we've shown that
actually when you look at the issues
that people are facing at moment whether
that's the cost of living the travel
chaos whether that's the situation with
the nhs we've got the answers to those
uh damaging questions that people are
asking at the moment boris johnson is
too busy naval gazing looking after
himself to look at the issues that many
working people of his country are facing
at the moment and that's damaging for
people because you know while rather
than saving and supporting people that
need that help now uh that vote for us
boris johnson is trying to save his own
skin
but how can you be ready when the leader
in the deputy leader are still facing a
police inquiry
well because you see here's the
difference with the police inquiry on
that occasion when we were in work we're
very confident that we were working and
we said categorically if we were issued
with a fixed penalty notice we would
resign because standards in public life
matter it might have be on me it might
be on care and it might be on boris
johnson he broke the rules that he set
and he's decided that those rules don't
apply to him i think it's damaging for
the public because you know if he breaks
those rules and lies to the public now
what else is he going to lie about you
know he's bringing everyone down i think
that's the issue here and the big
difference is that there is one
investigation into one work event that
we're very confident that we'll be uh
will be fine and if it isn't we've said
categorically that we shouldn't carry on
in post i think the prime minister over
120 fixed penalty notices numerous
parties going on in number 10 and he's
had a fixed penalty notice and he
doesn't think he should resign i think
that's appalling
but facts are facts aren't they and the
leader and the deputy leader of the
opposition have both been received
questionnaires so in other words
questionable police caution and they
still have a police investigation
outstanding you're not ready you can't
run the country yet while you're in that
position
well yeah of course we can you know
we're very ready to do that we've been
talking about the issues that matter to
people like the windfall tax on the
energy companies to support people to
look at a renewable energy program that
creates jobs in this country and deals
with our long-term energy needs to have
a new deal for working people that
provides
flexibility and work that pays for
people we've got a programme for change
and we're getting on with that and we're
very clear that if the police found us
to be guilty and give us a fixed penalty
notice we would resign we're very
confident that we didn't break the rules
and that we followed all the rules to
the letter well that's rolling the dice
isn't it and that's putting the party
the labour party in jeopardy because if
that did happen and you don't know if it
will or not if it did and you were in
the middle of a general election
campaign say the prime minister calls a
snap election then the leader and the
deputy leader would have to step down
what would that do for the uh
credibility of the party
well i don't think it's rolling the dice
i think it's called doing the right
thing i think there has to be a standard
a line that is drawn between the
contract of the british public and those
that hold public office it's an honor
and a privilege to have the roles that
myself and care have got and we know
that we do that um with the
goodwill of our party and with the
people that voted for us as mps we're
saying that if we broke the rules we
would resign we would not carry on boris
johnson says it doesn't matter and
there's laughed in people's faces and
lied to them when they couldn't see
their loved ones now if myself and kid
did resign we're not the only people in
the labour party we're a team we work
together in the labour party and have
done that and we work in the interests
of the public unlike boris johnson who
is a bit of a
tim pot uh dictator now who thinks he
could just carry on regardless anyway
i've broken his own rules and he's not
listening he's lost the confidence of
the british public and he's now lost the
confidence of many of his mps is limping
on because he doesn't think the rules
apply to him and i think he's gonna he's
gonna find out pretty
clear through the by-elections that
actually the british public do not like
liars people who break the rules and i
think it's going to be very damaging for
his party and for politics in general if
the prime minister carries on
tim bucht tin pot dictator that's very
strong words there from you this morning
ms rainer will the labour party be
calling for a vote of no confidence in
the whole cup in the whole government
well today we've set out a motion which
is about upholding standards in public
life which boris johnson again wants to
cherry-pick that the chair have been
very clear that the whole report should
be implemented and we agree with that so
we've put motion down today to ensure
that we at least set a bar that is
higher than where boris johnson is
so that we can you know restore some
trust in public office and of course
we'll look at all options going forward
but you know the prime minister ignores
he should have resigned months ago he
knows he broke the law he knows he lied
to the british public but you know he'll
just keep limping on because he doesn't
think the rules apply to him and he's
laughing at the general public and
taking them for fools and i think most
of the public will not move on while
boris johnson is prime minister
and in answer to my question will you be
calling for a vote of no confidence in
the whole government
well we'll see how we go on for the rest
of the week obviously we'll speak to
other um other parties as well but we're
very clear that the prime minister
doesn't have the confidence of the house
pretty clear from the votes of his own
mps that he's lost a lot of significant
confidence within his own political
party and if he had an ounce of
integrity which he removed from the code
he would have resigned by now
okay good to talk to you as always
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you
tomorrow when you hear angela rayna
there kay talking about boris johnson
limping on taking the public for fools
you get a flavor of what kierstarma is
going to be saying to the prime minister
at prime minister's questions every
single week for the rest of the time
that he remains in office and that is
the difficulty here we get the feeling
from boris johnson and very much from
dominic rob that everything's fine oh
we're just business as usual there's
always a few dissenting voices we're
just going to get on with our agenda and
everyone's going to move on and we're
going to draw a line and you know the
the 148 members of the conservative
party who said they had no confidence in
the prime minister can just row in
behind him clearly that's not going to
be as easy in the doing as it is in the
saying and
labour have been given an opportunity
here to um to prod the prime minister
about this every week every little bit
of dissent from an mp he gets and the
big question i think tory mps are waking
up to this morning is does boris johnson
try to bring in some of those rebels and
it's hard to see how he can does he sack
people in his existing cabinet and bring
in some of his detractors um if he does
that he looks like he's sort of taken
hostage by his opponents if he doesn't
um then you know then then others in the
party will be more critical of him as
well you you um you know you bring in
some of the um sort of liberal left of
the party and then you upset those on
the right so he's in this um he's
in a way this is the worst of all worlds
as his former advisor will walden put it
he's now stuck there but his levers of
power are very limited okay thanks very
much tomorrow for now let's go up to
berry in greater manchester home to two
of the most marginal tourist suits in
the country phrases there in berry north
for us this morning hi fraser what's the
mood there this morning
morning kay well the mood is
pretty buoyant in favor of uh boris
johnson in fact you would think that uh
somewhere like this up north there's
obviously
serious financial issues up here
economic issues and so on uh that people
would not be too happy with him but the
majority of people that i spoke to today
say well this vote's over he's still in
let's get him let's let him carry on
with it uh people didn't think he'd done
a bad job during the pandemic a lot of
people think that he did okay making
sure that brexit went through which was
why a lot of people lent him their votes
in the first place one chap i spoke to
said that he voted conservative for the
first time ever in the last election and
he said he would vote conservative again
despite the partygate scandal despite
various despite various allegations
despite various concerns about boris
johnson's leadership uh people do seem
to be still backing him here now in
terms of the
the marginal nature of this constituency
it's
it's a majority of only 105 for james
daley now he did say that uh he
understands people's concerns but he
says he continued to back the prime
minister because of his belief in
leveling up the north
okay thanks very much indeed i'm going
to just move slightly out of the way
because look what's happening here at
downing street uh tomorrow this is the
bunching that has been uh put up
for the queen's silver jubilee the
party's over
yes i think it is um
yes it's difficult to avoid the uh this
image but yes the bunting is taken over
and the the about turn from the um
pageantry of the jubilee on sunday we
now know that boris johnson knew this
was coming to yesterday's back to
reality okay as we continue to look at
those uh pictures to ed davey a leader
of the liberal democrats is joining us
now hello to you uh mr david just
reflecting on the fact that the bunting
is coming down here at number 10 downing
street and i'll say before you do the
party's over some might say
well it ought to be
i think there should be a vote of no
confidence in the prime minister
in the house of commons
liberal democrats are tabling a motion
of no confidence in boris johnson
and if it can be debated
i hope a lot of those 148 mps who
clearly don't have confidence the prime
minister will vote with the liberal
democrats and other opposition parties
so we can remove this prime minister you
know there are millions of people k out
there families and pensioners who are
suffering they're facing a summer of
discontent with rising prices the cost
living crisis nhs crisis and now the
travel and holiday crisis we need to see
this prime minister gone and that's why
liberal democrats will put forward a
vote of no confidence in the prime
minister today
um so you will who what support do you
think you will have or from where i did
put that actually to angela rainer and
she said they are keeping a watching
brief on that
well i'm sure if it was debated that all
opposition parties would get behind it
and now we know 148 concert mps don't
have confidence in the prime minister
this is the chance to speak for the
british people
so i hope the
uh leader of the house doesn't duck this
and allows this debate to to to go on
if he stops it he clearly
feels that the prime minister would lose
and then it will be in the hands of
people in east devon in the tiverton and
huntington by-election where liberal
democrats are challenging the
conservatives and the people there could
speak for the british people switch from
the conservatives to back the liberal
democrats to send a message to
conservative mps that this
lying law-breaking prime minister has to
go
um
just to clarify because i'm a bit
confused and you and you're an expert at
these sort of things tomorrow's just
pointed out to me is it a version of
confidence in the prime minister that
you're tabling or a vote of no
confidence in the government
it's a vote of no competence in the
prime minister it's a very important
distinction uh 148 mps conservative mps
yesterday voted for a motion of no comps
in the prime minister
so that's why we want that same motion
to the house of commons so those
conservative mps can join the liberal
democrats and other opposition parties
to express what i've felt for a long
time on behalf of the many people i
spoke to on the doorsteps the british
people who don't have confidence in him
it seems to me that there are
unfortunately too many conservative mps
who aren't listening to british peop the
british people they are they aren't in
tune with what people are saying and
thinking and they're not
allowing our country to move on and so
we can have solutions to what i think is
going to be a summer of discontent if we
don't see changes
what do you mean by that
well we've you know about cost living
crisis kay we've talked about that
before we've got the nhs and care crisis
we're now looking at a travel and
holiday crisis you know people are
having problems getting to and fro from
the country in the airports and at the
channel ports we're seeing people
applying months ahead for their
passports and the government's passport
office not able to to deal with those
passport applications this is a
government in crisis it's completely
incompetent it can't do the day job and
part of the reason
is that the prime minister is too busy
trying to save his own skin they're
putting his interests the interests of
the conservative party ahead of the
national interest and that's not right
that's why this prime minister has to go
uh but rules his rules uh he only had to
win by one vote in the end he won by a
more than a comfortable enough majority
to continue
on well okay those are the rules of the
conservative party i'm talking about the
rules of the house of commons
and the rules of the house of commons
say that if there's a vote of no
confidence in the prime minister then he
would have to go
so this doesn't need a change in
conservative party rules i mean if they
want to do that's up to them
this is about the people who elected on
behalf of the british people to serve
them being able to express their view
in the prime minister that's why liberal
democrats are tabling this motion today
and i think if the commons
could debate that and hopefully vote for
it and see the back of boris johnson
then we really could see the sorts of
policies that liberal democrats have
been arguing for for example a cut in
vat to give every family out there a 600
pounds tax cut and that would lower the
rate of inflation because it would take
prices in our shops down it will help
struggling businesses that sort of
constructive policy that liberal
democrats want to see to help our
economy to help struggling families and
i think if we can remove boris johnson
then we can we can open the door to that
sort of policy to help help people who
are struggling
okay so ed thanks very much indeed for
joining us much appreciated thank you um
tamara is still here in 20 seconds
tomorrow tell me uh whether that is
likely to uh be passed a vote of no
confidence first hurdle will be getting
time in the commons and not clear
whether the speaker would allow that
doubt it would happen today so for
another day and will labour bring a vote
of no confidence in the whole government
has happened several times uh under
theresa may that's probably a bigger
question because then that might get
time and the lib dems could support that
and that will put tory mps in a
difficult position okay thanks very much
indeed for explaining that uh
all today's top stories well mostly from
here actually coming up in just a moment
here on sky news breakfast stay tuned